l'appel au cessez-le-feu finalement
entendus par les deux parties le chef du
gn a annoncé ce dimanche qu'il acceptait
la trêve
fayez elle sa rage a toutefois prévenu
qu'il se réservait le droit de riposter
en cas d'attaqué de l'autre camp
auparavant son rival de l'armée
nationale libyenne avait lui aussi
répondu favorablement à l'appel à la
trêve lancé mercredi par ankara et
moscou le porte-parole de la nl commandé
par aly fall tard en a fait l'annoncé à
la télévision
le commandement général des forces
armées arabe libyenne annoncent un
cessez-le-feu des opérations militaires
dans la région de l'ouest effectif à
partir de minuit le 12 janvier 2020 nous
demandons à la partie adverse de mettre
en oeuvre ce cessez-le-feu à la même
heure la riposte sera sévère en cas de
violation de la trêve par le camp
adverse une suspension des combats alors
que rallye faf tarde à lancer une
offensive sur tripoli depuis le mois
d'avril ce répit intervient après un
intense ballet diplomatique cette
semaine conduits notamment par la
turquie et la russie les deux pays se
sont imposés ces dernières semaines
comme des acteurs clés en libye ankara
ainsi déployer des militaires en janvier
pour se tenir le gn à deux failles
hazell sa rage de son côté la russie
soutient les troupes de rallye fabre
tard le conflit en libye était justement
au coeur des discussions ce samedi lors
d'une rencontre entre la chancelière
allemande et le président russe
nous avons surtout discuter de la libye
où malheureusement les actions
militaires à grande échelle se
poursuivent et où les activités
terroristes se développe alors que les
secteurs économique et social se
détériore au détriment de tous
cela mine la stabilité dans la région
mais a aussi une influence négative sur
l'europe
de son côté anglais la merkel redoutent
que le pays ne devienne une seconde
syrie elle a annoncé qu'une conférence
sur la libye se tiendrait prochainement
sous l'égide des nations unies à berlin
objectif donner une chance aux parties
libyennes de rétablir la paix dans le
pays
[Musique]